[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark barnard a conic on
everybody it was a packed weekend I
think for everybody all concerned how
many people let's do it this way who
didn't go to comic-con put your hands
together holy [ __ ]
what what the boy did you cry all
weekend and [ __ ] how many people did go
put your hands in yeah
alright so we're gonna spend a lot of
time talking about the events of the
comic-con before we go back into the
past let's take care of the present man
we are here at the scum and villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands goes to the
folks at home know you are real it was a
packed a few days man yeah how you doing
I'm still I'm good everyone keeps asking
you tired and I'm like oh no man like
that I I love that kind of [ __ ] because
I'm a challenge stoner like I like to
you know get [ __ ] too big to work and
then somehow work through it like that's
the fun of it for me so doing that
adding spinning as many plates as we did
this year Comic Con was just like
honestly at a certain point it's like
the Train is [ __ ] moving don't even
think about it like I was sitting I was
on the IMD boat interviewing people and
you're meeting casts and talking about
TV shows and that are yet to come and
movies that haven't happened yet and you
know I like to be able to like
personally interact with everybody but
it's like some cats I just don't [ __ ]
know so I would get like all sorts of oh
my god I didn't I don't know enough
about these cats then I would just like
[ __ ] wing it and so
it just kind of worked down stuff but it
was real pack this is the busiest set
been adhikam constants like the one year
we did geeking out I was doing the IMD
boat and geeking out and stuff like so
this was mostly IMD boat stuff I had a
Hall H panel on Saturday night I did you
guys went thank you or you heard of it
thank you then I had a con Panna on
Sunday which was really fun a panel
where I was on the panel like for my
Hall H panel I brought out Jason I
brought out Harley and I brought out and
Melissa Benoist and you know I was like
yeah there's these [ __ ] people
let's do Q&A we sat down and nobody
asked them [ __ ] so they just dutifully
sat there for an hour and a half they're
so sweet thank god Melissa Pinoys just
like the light of the world and [ __ ]
she was like I'm just happy to be here
and I would have been like I'm [ __ ]
bored to be here man like all they want
to do is talk about you so I got to be
on a panel where I was not the focus of
the panel it was a look back at
comic-con and stuff and a look forward
with a bunch of comic-con like legends
like Billy Tucci was on the panel he was
going back to like the nineties Meyer
people who were like famous at comic-con
long before I ever entered the business
so it was kind of kucik like was the the
guy moderating the panel Wow
yeah it was really [ __ ] cool so I did
that and then I did a signing with
pernil I was point there as if she's
here but for Neil who you know did the
art on my hip girl run and she did the
DC superhero girls so we just signing at
the booth the weirdest wonderful things
were I put my hands in cement lijing
them got the folks who had the TCL
Chinese Theatre folks they got a theater
down in San Diego called the theater box
and so they did a ceremony man where me
and J put our hands in cement and wrote
in and [ __ ] like that and I love that
kind of [ __ ] like honestly like you know
I've never I've never tried to perfect
my craft to the point of like let's try
to win an award or something like that
that kind of [ __ ] don't do it for me but
if somebody's like you could [ __ ]
write in [ __ ] I'm like oh my god I'm a
writer you know
it's like I love that me and Jay did it
and it was really cool and the notion
that like you know that's theater
theater sticks around like our
handprints will stick around long before
us until [ __ ] people are walking by
one day going who were these people I'm
sure people are gonna walk by today
going who are these people and [ __ ] but
still it was really [ __ ] cool but the
biggest thing that I did at comic-con
this year was we released the trailer
for Jay and Silent Bob reboot it was we
were supposed to do it in Hall age but I
knew for all H I had the trailer and I
had a we showed a couple scenes from the
movie as well so just kind of get ahead
of the clutter of what was coming for
comic-con we were all ready so I was
like let's pull the trigger on Thursday
night [ __ ] it let's throw it up and that
we did and and I you know my [ __ ]
clenched so [ __ ] tight right before
we release it because this has been like
my best friend for the last like two and
a half years like you know whenever I
was bored lonely high which is like all
the [ __ ] time
whenever I just wanted to go someplace
else whenever I wanted to make pretend
and [ __ ] like that
I had chainsaw Bob reboot you know I've
been working on I got 12 drafts of the
script at the end of the day and stuff
so I would just always go back in and
tinker it was it was my safe place and
then one day we got to make the movie
and then I got to see what it looked
like I put the movie together so since
we wrapped once again it's been my place
to go every morning I had a reason to
get up to be like oh I'm gonna go ahead
at the flick and oh my god here come the
sound cues let's score cues from Jim
Venable and so that's being built and
here come the CG effects from Arman and
the folks at encore so like you're
starting to see everything but with
every step forward that means it's a
step toward completion and there goes
the thing that I go to like I've I'm
about to lose my hobby and my safe place
the place that I go to where I'm like
well if nothing else I'm gonna work on
this and I'll take care of this and
improve this we've locked picture and
we've locked sound like we're literally
done there's nothing left to do with Jay
and Silent Bob reboot
sell it market it [ __ ] like that but in
terms of making it we were [ __ ] done
so it was really kind of weird to put
the trailer out there because that's
where it officially ends where it stops
being mine and starts being other
people's and they can have an opinion on
it and up until this point I've loved
this thing like a [ __ ] child man like
this is my favorite thing I've ever done
it really encapsulates who the [ __ ] I am
but at the same time I know me I'm the
type of person that's like you see this
thing right here this represents
everything that I am I put my all into
it my heart and soul breathes in this
[ __ ] thing without it I'm nothing
what do you think if people like we
think it's a piece of [ __ ] and I'm like
you're right let's kill this [ __ ]
thing right now I'd sell out on [ __ ] so
[ __ ] quickly so before the [ __ ]
trailer came out I was real sad cuz I'm
like [ __ ] if the whole world hates it
then I got started holding it at arm's
length and making fun of it like I do a
Jersey girl and [ __ ] mall rat yoga
hosers and [ __ ] like that it's got to
start beating it up before other people
do and that's heartbreaking because I
love this and like you know I was at
this point with the movie where I'm like
who couldn't love this movie oh my god
like I loved so much and that's how I
felt about [ __ ] yoga hosers as well
and I met a lot of people didn't like
that [ __ ] movie right to my face so I
right before we released the trailer my
[ __ ] is super clenched because I'm
like [ __ ] man this could be the moment
everybody [ __ ] turns on the movie and
then I got a turn on the [ __ ] movie
but it was received really well like and
I was so [ __ ] relieved because now I
still get to like it unencumbered
without having to make excuses for it or
some such [ __ ] or play some store to do
goofy role about it so I that was the
best part of con for me then when we had
the panel we played the trailer anyway
even though it was out there and hearing
it play in a room was magnificent here
in the reaction to it because we've
never screened the movie publicly we
haven't had like you know test
screenings or anything like that so
there's [ __ ] that I think is funny but
I'm like I've never here to heard it
beyond like you know a room of like 20
people or something like that
never heard it in the real world so
putting the trailer in front of Hall H
which like we didn't have 6500 ma
but we have 5000 which is not [ __ ]
bad man when here in 5000 [ __ ] people
react and laugh at something that like
two and a half years ago you're like
[ __ ] I hope they think this is funny is
insanely gratifying in a moment I'll
take with me to my grave is me and the
kid were laying on the stage and Hall H
like you know we started running the
clips and I think Jason kind of went
backstage to get Melissa cuz we were
bringing her out next and so me and
Harley just kind of laid on the stage
and watched the trailer and then you
know we have the tables behind us and
[ __ ] so we couldn't see anybody but you
could hear the [ __ ] crowd and every
time like a roar of laughter came over
the tables the kid looked at me like oh
my god like you did it and [ __ ] like
that I was like I did it with no help
like we did it well again we did it was
really [ __ ] gratifying and stuff and
I think she's a little gunshot to
because like she's got a lot of heat for
yoga hosers but she's wonderful in the
movie and it seems to play in the
trailer and stuff like that so it was
all around a good weekend and I said
that on the IMD boat I'm like Friday
morning I was like I'm just so thankful
that I get to like go to work and
interview people in a good mood because
like we didn't think about and releasing
the trailer on Thursday what if the
whole world had been like [ __ ] your
trailer and [ __ ] then I'd have to
interview people for three days on the
IMD Belt going like why try everyone
hates everything anyway anyway how
Supergirl so it was it was a relief to
be able to go to work every day with a
little spring in the step and [ __ ]
interview the Russo brothers who you
know I'm always blowing them up and
whatnot and and they turned the tables
on me because they were like we saw the
[ __ ] trailer it's amazing I'm like
[ __ ] you you make amazing I make
adequate
is really cool it's a cool weekend all
around we didn't get to announce the
thing that we've been talking about that
we've been working on for some time now
but I from what I understand that
announcement is coming soon no yeah I
mean I couldn't it's coming on it's in
August I believe I we had a you know
what I'm not gonna believe I [ __ ]
know for a fact they're gonna tell the
world in August there's a bakery
convention in Anaheim and that's where
we're revealing yeah man it's but we
didn't we didn't make any big
announcements I mean well my big
announcement was here's my movie yours
might look like and [ __ ] what did you do
at the car uh I I did have a big
announcement at the con I eight years
ago I started writing a graphic novel I
wasn't sure what it was gonna be but it
was it was inspired by my daughter it
was inspired by like when she was three
three-and-a-half four years old she kind
of wasn't doing [ __ ] the way other kids
were supposed to be doing this she
wasn't like oh she was [ __ ] fine
but not like she wasn't playing with
other kids we're supposed to her
language wasn't where I was supposed to
be so we had our evaluated we had her
tested and and she came back autistic
on the spectrum midway through she's not
she's not completely nonverbal but she
is in no way ever gonna go to like
college it's not in the scheme of things
for her but the thing that I can never
get from her is she'll say I want
chicken nuggets or I want apple juice or
I want to watch Nemo I don't ever get
I'm happy or I'm sad or I'm afraid or
any of that stuff she doesn't have
access to her emotions that way so for
the entirety of her life I've been
wondering what's been going on in her
head and so I decided to write a graphic
novel about that about the sort of
fantasy world that an autistic kid
builds inside her own head and the
journey that she takes to go out of it
to travel through it and because I'm a
[ __ ] nerd it's a question you know
it's story it's got like underwater
pirates and Dragons and lava monsters
and all that [ __ ] and a bunch of nights
and one request and we're doing things
but it is about answering the unknowable
question for me and so I've been just
sitting on this book for a long time
like it pitch it to a cup of people and
they didn't like it or they liked you
but they wanted to change it then [ __ ]
it I don't for this one now this is this
needs to be what it is and and then I
pitched it to comiXology but a year and
a half ago because they were starting up
their comiXology originals program and
they said yeah we'll do it you want to
change it not exactly as it is like you
tell us what you want to do and we'll do
it and and so we announced it at the
show like they hung a big [ __ ] banner
from the rafters of the Convention
Center adora and the distance it's
called and we had a preview that went up
on a w.com my old alma mater like five
pages of the book and and we gave away
[ __ ] pins red lines around the booth
every time we sat down and sign it so to
be able to like talk about this thing
that's been so close to my heart for so
long and just share people it's been
awesome and when did you start how long
ago first draft over eight years ago
[ __ ] man what a [ __ ] long journey so
to finally be able to be like here
and yeah and so I brought for her Q&A I
brought some pins the pins that we were
giving away at the booth I stole because
it's my [ __ ] book - right stop me
these are mine that's tremendous man
[ __ ] a yeah and then I was also there
for karlova row which had his big
[ __ ] coming-out party at comic con
carnival row for those unfamiliar with
the show you'll get familiar with it's
the fairy [ __ ] show the show where
the fairies actually fought oh yeah
there's all kinds of [ __ ] yeah and
they [ __ ] and when a fairy [ __ ] a human
they lift off the ground and [ __ ] oh
yeah it's so I'm telling you that's how
they pitched it to me I'm like I'm in
here's my money mafia but that show did
blow up Scott Orlando Bloom Cara
Delevingne
yeah and that's the show that you've
been working on your working on season
two I'm working on season two season one
premieres on Labor Day so they had they
[ __ ] took over a city block like
Amazon just built this whole [ __ ]
like experience the activation the
activation and and the stars were there
and they dulled they did the rounds and
they went on the boat yeah they came on
the IMD boat I interviewed them all I
heard the lovely story cuz Travis
Beacham is a creator of the show and
Travis Beacham don't man you're gonna
ruin my [ __ ] reputation as a hard guy
I know but you clearly did well earned
reputation as a hard-ass who cries all
the [ __ ] it but uh but so Travis Beacham
wrote the wrote this feature screenplay
in college this long it was on the very
first blacklist which is the the annual
list of the greatest unproduced
screenplays in Hollywood was on the very
first one of those it's not like 18
years old and he's been living with this
story in his brain since college and
like Gael Missoula Toro was going to
make a movie out of it and decided not
to then he and Travis made Pacific Rim
and then it made its way to television
but it took forever and they start a
production like four years ago and now
it's finally coming out
and so he's been he's been carrying this
load with him for this long and so they
and of course they're doin the [ __ ]
like PR rounds and there's China shiny
pretty actors and Cara Delevingne and
Orlando Bloom and Tamzin merchant and
David Jesse and and they're all gorgeous
and so of course they go to do press for
stuff and the four actors are always put
in the stools because that's what you do
and and I ran into Travis after they all
went into the boat he's like listen man
I know you do this podcast with Kevin
but he did the awesomest thing for me is
that I kind of like went up with the
cast and and and then the PR people were
like what are you now now we just want
the actors and so he's standing kind of
disheveled and dejected off to the side
and keV goes hey man what do you do
I created the show you know like get
this man a [ __ ] stool like put it
give him like get him a stool like I
want to talk to the guy who made this
[ __ ] up and been living with it forever
and he was so touched like it literally
took he's like I don't I just like
everywhere else they just want to talk
to the actors but cab sat me down he's
like I want to talk to you too and he
was like visibly moved and I just being
able to tell his story and tell his
story about his story it was sweet he
gave us great content man like at the
end of the day I like that look the cast
is wonderful and of course they're very
easy to look at and stuff but like we're
gonna engage with the material we're
gonna care about these pretty people
because of the things they say and the
things that they're going through it
begins with the written word and at
Comic Con like you know on a late-night
talk-show fine you put up the actor the
actress but like for comic-con it's like
[ __ ] our culture where you know we
celebrate where it comes from
authors are [ __ ] rock stars and stuff
so I saw him getting kind of like shuts
off that not a hardcore like way but it
was just like they were like now it just
cast just cast and so once I saw that I
was like who he must like like who are
you and he was just like I created that
get that [ __ ] up here man we need you
and he told us a great story about I
wrote this thing was 18 years ago 16
years ago whatever it was and it's like
was the spark plug behind his career
like it got everything going he's got a
career like
you know vug would Pacific Pacific Rim
that clashed the Titans movie he's one
of like 20 dudes who wrote in the 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea movie that never
got made like he's just been a working
screenwriter for decade and a half but
this thing was always kind of what he
felt the sacrificial lamb like I had to
write this and that kicked off the
career but it was never to be made so to
[ __ ] have it come to fruition that
many years later he walked through the
activation more so than anyone else like
the cast went through there looks like
our set this [ __ ] guy walked through
and he was like I this was my dream this
was the thing that got me to where I was
going on life and I thought that was
enough I thought this was the fuel turns
out it's still the [ __ ] vehicle we
just had to build the car
[ __ ] astounding stories I was so glad
to pull him up there majid that was
somebody else to there shunted off
another creator and I was a kid up here
man like it's tough to ask the cast to
like hey where'd this come from like on
my agent but you'll get the truth from
like the writer and stuff you get some
real meaty [ __ ] and and if I'm watching
a bunch of videos about interviews and
[ __ ] like yeah I like you know if I
getting the actors and actresses but
like what's probably gonna get me more
interested is like where'd this come
from
and and his backstory was compelling
yeah and so to like ride shotgun with
him as he gets to walk through the
activation which I mean the show is kind
of about this kind of Victorian London
that also has like fairies and pucks and
centaurs and mythological creatures who
are the immigrant class and so they
built like a Street of this section of
London yeah and they had like dudes and
makeup and the [ __ ] horns and like
everything and to watch him walk through
corners of his own mind like with this
[ __ ] camera phone out like a little
tear streaming down his face it's like
every time I saw how awesome it was I
mean just to watch to watch a guy's
dream come true is it's like you can
turn on every corner of comic-con and
see that like you know kids who you know
come from all over the [ __ ] country
symbol or owner of comic-con where we
saw it as well man
Dora
come true for you how [ __ ] he does
but to see that like rich so large it's
it is why we go is because there's
things that you love and things did you
find and people who love those things
too and there's there's a corner of that
Convention Center just for you you just
have to find it
agreed did you go to any parties uh I
went to a handful I went to a handful I
am too I am very Murtaugh about this
words I'm getting too old for this [ __ ]
but like my every time I go to comic-con
my brain thinks it is exactly as old as
I was the first time I went my brain is
like [ __ ] you're 27 years old you can
go all night and then like two days in
my knees like [ __ ] you are 47
sit your ass down I can't feel my feet
to Kaiser I was I powered through I'll
be honest with you honor you know I got
some sleeves of decent sleep each night
like six seven hours or something like
that but I read that I smoked caviar
gold and the guy that the guy that
created it man it's got Mike he created
a strain three different strains for me
one was a sativa what he does is he
takes you know a plant and he sucks out
all the THC and CBD 's and all that
stuff
and rejects it into the plant at the
level he wants it so he can dictate how
much the THC content of the [ __ ]
plant katene C content of every joint
and stuff so that whether you make it
here whether you make it there it's
always the same in nature plants do what
they want it's like you know having
babies you want five girls you're gonna
get whatever [ __ ] comes out man and so
even if you want five [ __ ] plants
that put out 20% you know that may not
[ __ ] happen his process which he made
he made up invented because he said I
couldn't get high off weed in a
dispensary anymore I had to [ __ ] find
something and so he made this super weed
in truth which is science I'm a
scientist so he made me some strange
because in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
there are three strains that are at the
center of the movie three strains of
weed and so he came up
them in real life so there's a Teva and
there's a hybrid and there's an indica
and sativa joint he brought over my
house he's gone you guys smoke this cuz
he's like what do you want to taste like
he's like because I can make it taste
like anything and I said well like I'm
just used to smoking weed tastes like
dirt and shits so I was like well as I
gonna be great if it tasted like
breakfast and he was like I'll see what
I can do
he he goes I'll see what I could do and
he went [ __ ] back and he came up with
this I don't know how else to describe
it but it's it tastes like like maples
here maple oatmeal like instant oatmeal
like it tastes like [ __ ] breakfast
it's it's it honestly it tastes Canadian
it's [ __ ] maple as hell so anyway
that's it's like flavor profile but it's
you know he came over he goes you ready
for this I was like yeah totally he's
like this joint has never existed in
nature before and I was like what is it
and he goes it's 25% THC which you know
is high but allowed as high as [ __ ]
you know caviar Gold goes way [ __ ]
deep but he goes it's 30% CBD I said
how's that possible he goes because I
can do that so he pumped this [ __ ]
sativa joint which is the joint that you
smoked Oh like hey I'm gonna go work
indica is the one that's like let's
watch South Park but sativa is the one
we liked hey man I got some [ __ ] to do
and [ __ ] so he took that and put it in
like [ __ ] a bunch more CBD so not
only you [ __ ] like have a crisp eye
and [ __ ] you're you're beyond ready to
[ __ ] work so I was interviewing the
[ __ ] out of people man
holy [ __ ] right before I sat down with
the snowpiercer [ __ ] people cast I was
like took a big smoke out in the tent
[ __ ] and then I went up to interview
people and at one point we're talking
Jennifer Connelly's on that show and
stuff and she's sitting - right to my
left or right or wherever the [ __ ] goes
on here [ __ ] to my right and she's
talking about I asked her questions
she's talking about the show and I'm
listening to her and finally I just kind
of get lost in what she's saying and
when she finishes I was like I'm sorry I
can't help but think you're a [ __ ]
little girl from labyrinth man like yes
and I've got an Oscar I told her I was
like I just watched that movie with my
kid I was about 15 years too late she
kind of liked it but like I love that
[ __ ] movie so after the interview I
think I blew her mind cuz she was like
nice meeting you I said some girls
that's my [ __ ] jam and she was like
nobody has ever said that I said I
bought it on VHS from choice video and I
was kind of [ __ ] love that move on
big fan of Canada you were great man she
was like thanks I wonder if she thinks
like I made that movie like [ __ ] 30
years ago can't you pick something more
recent [ __ ] I could have said
The Rocketeer and [ __ ] like that anyway
that was that was it was I was on fire
for the interviews and [ __ ] because I
was just like all right let's talk to
people who shows I have no idea what
they're about I start I start putting it
right on Front Street with them being
like whatever you know have you guys
even started making this show and
they're like no not yet I'm like what
the [ __ ] what are we supposed to talk
about and we just went in different
directions so yeah four seasons deep
[ __ ] yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
does that joint come with like an audio
sound that comes with it like
mmm-hmm no they all it just it's the
sound of satisfaction and serenity which
is like this because I watched the I'm
will get into a little later but the Top
Gun maverick trailer oh [ __ ] yeah like
it dropped to comic-con and that trailer
is nothing but nostalgia and it begins
with that [ __ ] sound of the like mmm
and then Jeff screaming and that the
[ __ ] little Vangelis core kicks in
yeah like oh no you're just doing that
like you don't even have to have a movie
here you could just do this [ __ ]
he's got the motorcycle I remember the
motors and he's put in the jacket on I
maybe it is gonna be probably Paul is
there a mood IRA of their two movies
just didn't do his [ __ ] he did in the
first movie but older I'm fine with that
I I it was almost like you know we put
out our trailer and we're like we're
[ __ ] chock-a-block full of 90s
nostalgia Top Gun 2 was like hold my
joint and they went to the 80s man they
beat us they went back to the [ __ ]
80s for their nostalgia and [ __ ] it was
kind of funny though I'm watching the
trailer and then they get to him at the
end we're not in the am but when they
finally cuts in as if you're like you
know well they're gonna cut to Roger
Rabbit of course I keep talking about
I'm and Shelley or this you're that
you're that you're a booking maverick
and they cut to him he looks [ __ ]
good he honestly doesn't look like he's
aged much from that first movie my teeth
are better but that's about it
yeah like thicker not thicker like he's
chunkier but like more muscular probably
in his older age at imagine but I got to
tell you man like a [ __ ] fear for
this kid's life like he's a great actor
man like [ __ ] anybody that's liked oh no
he ain't I love Tom Cruise as an actor
Tom Cruise somebody [ __ ] convinced
Tom Cruise somewhere along the way that
unless he is risking his life
people aren't gonna go see the movies
anymore [ __ ] cuz this [ __ ] Top Gun
trailer they literally put a camera or a
GoPro on a [ __ ] jet and it takes off
and you're like wait is that the cell of
the movie is the like look we let him
[ __ ] fly isn't that [ __ ] up for
real he's flying for real he ain't even
maverick anymore he's [ __ ] Tom Cruise
and [ __ ] like that
this guy's gonna [ __ ] hurt himself I
saw that [ __ ] video of him busted his
ankle on the last [ __ ] stunt he did
and [ __ ] like that
it's crazy man Jackie Chan yeah it's
kind of what he's doing man he's just
throwing himself a danger left and right
[ __ ] do kaboom all right so we got a
bunch to talk about we got some weight
that happen all right man so marks got
news to go through man mark used to work
in the news and any aggregated news for
you tonight so we're gonna talk about
the news and I bet you it's all the news
that came out of Comic Con give it up
for mark he's got the nose I bring you
the finest copy-pasting in all the land
Marvel went to comic-con whoa hold on
[ __ ] yeah like work kiss me work my
nipples don't go right for my [ __ ]
[ __ ] man like hugging once we get to
Marvel it's gonna be all night long so
there must have been other news at Comic
Con before Hall H happened with yeah but
we know that you know Warner Brothers
didn't bring any bug in DC things or
anything like that but we do know that
DC was well represented by the CW shows
and they did give us some cool [ __ ]
about crisis on Infinite Earths which is
their big crossover this year it seems
as if to coincide with arrows final
season they are just kind of like going
[ __ ] balls out they got Burt Ward to
come back to play [ __ ] Robin
in crisis on Infinite Earths they
announced that yeah holy [ __ ]
I mean I'm sure it wasn't hard to get
Burt Ward to come back it's Robin let me
check my schedule 2019 is that the year
you said yeah I'm free he's he's he's
got a business right like you know he
sells dog food he does he's such a
[ __ ] hardcore dog fan that he's made
laughed as loud as I did it yeah that
was that Riddick laughter reticule Burt
Ward will have the last laugh on you if
you have no vision
he makes this [ __ ] food that makes
dogs live long he's got dogs that are
like 150 years old and [ __ ] i'm much CBD
does he put it exactly pumps it up high
but yeah he don't he obviously don't
need the working [ __ ] but we had him on
comic book man hmm
and we had to wait like a couple years
to get him it wasn't like he answered on
the first phone call I think it was like
four or five seasons in maybe six
seasons in but he does he's got he's got
a life you don't you don't need this
[ __ ] it's very [ __ ] sweet that he
actually said yes to it that is pretty
cool think about it it's not like he's
sitting there gone oh my god this'll
kickstart my [ __ ] career like I think
Burt's in his 70s at this point so if
he's doing it I I don't I don't know him
that well I've interviewed him at cons
I've been on a couple panels with him
and talk to him backstage my impression
generally speaking of the guy and and
having worked with in the first
structure of CW as well nobody getting
rich you know yeah doing part like that
he's doing it because he thinks fans
will dig it which is really [ __ ]
sweet because again he's a he's an old
man you know what I'm saying like and
and to you know he knows he's probably
gonna have to put on some form of
costume he's gonna have to climb up a
building yes and he may not have bare
legs but he's gonna be wearing a very
Robin s costume and [ __ ] like that
and you know he don't he don't have to
do that at this point he did that
throughout his life the fact that he's
doing it now I think is kind of like
sweet it's him doing like look kids will
love it let's [ __ ] put on the Domino
mask one more time you know it's pretty
dope and she had the only sad part is
you know we wish Adam West was here to
do it with them like you've gotten to a
place where they're doing a crisis event
apparently they're you know they're
playing with the their media heritage
and lineage so Brandon Ralph has been
announced as spite as Superman that'd be
amazing
as Superman let's do this one last time
my name is Peter Park
he's gonna [ __ ] Superman want one
more time for the first time since
Superman returned returns and [ __ ] like
that he normally plays the atom of Ray
Palmer so on one of the alternate worlds
he's going to be Superman and Tyler
hoechlin is also gonna be Superman as he
is in the CW world and during a panel
Brandon ripped open a shirt and he
showed off the kingdom come ass so he's
probably playing Kingdom Come Superman
that's like [ __ ] incredibly that's
where is this place right now so DC it
definitely had some [ __ ] cool they
did they have some other cool [ __ ]
coming down the pike that we can't talk
about but we know things
if I find us after the show dude
don't find ourselves a joke because if I
say [ __ ] I'm gonna get fired if he says
[ __ ] he's just gonna get hated on yeah
but no it's gonna be [ __ ] nuts yeah
it's it's even it's bigger this crisis
thing is [ __ ] huge big big not just
like the normal they've been doing a
great job at these crossovers at CW but
this is massive but they're doing this
one with this one is pretty [ __ ] big
it shows that you know they've grown
that into such a cottage industry that
there's a lot of years where they were
told you can't use this you can't do
that you can't touch these characters
and now they're being given more carte
blanche which is what they deserve
because they've shown themselves to be
not just competent storytellers but like
[ __ ] storytellers that stick to you
know the storylines that would read that
we've seen before and stuff loyal to the
storylines and passionate as well so I
can't wait that's gonna be amazing our
friend of the show David to small change
yes launched a comic book that he's
writing in San Diego I was so happy for
him he told me about this back he's Dave
if you've seen the Jay and Silent Bob
reboot trailer he opens the trailer with
Danelle Rawlings and stuff and so while
he was there shooting the flick he told
me about this cool idea for a show for a
book that's what he's doing as a comic
book but this could easily be a [ __ ]
TV show tell them what it is count
Crawley reluctant midnight monster
hunter which I'm on board just for the
[ __ ] main yeah haha let's see takes
place in mid-80s and centers on a once
rising TV journalist who moves back to
her hometown in the Midwest
after she hits a career snaggle with
alcoholism she hosts a nightly creature
feature but soon learns that her job
comes with hidden duties hunting
monsters themselves count Crowley her
missing Queen SS was one of the last
appointment appointed master hunters in
the world monsters are actually real and
are trying to control the world's news
and information but yeah man this sounds
[ __ ] dope and I am so happy that the
small chain is expanding his weird
[ __ ] empire in between starring in
all of the movies that I love I know
he's [ __ ] in so many goddamn flicks
but yeah that is a cool project you can
easily see how that could be like TV
show or a movie is totally he's gonna be
in dune which I think might have wrapped
production already he's gonna be in
guardians 3 whenever the hell that
happens squad 2 1 2 2 2 so yes it is so
awesome I'm sorry that I [ __ ] up your
signing system not at all good
did you see the the Star Trek Picard
trailer or us Trekkie
I am a Loki Trekkie yeah like you know
[ __ ] yeah I guess that's I yeah I
know enough about it but I can't I can't
say I've seen every episode of next
generation I've certainly not seen every
episode of the classic series and stuff
but I have enough of a working knowledge
of it and respect for it I've seen all
the movies in theaters and stuff so yeah
I guess I'm gonna look a Loki Trekkie
did you watch the trailer loved it
absolutely loved it like look when they
pulled up in the draw drawer sorry my
New Jersey came out
and you saw data and pieces I was like
oh my god man like that's a brilliant
tease they'll probably make us wait
until the last episode of this and then
the trailer ends with [ __ ] data and
you're like they're doing everything
right
like they tease it and then I gave them
to you and then you know there's reports
of more folks coming dad Jonathan Frakes
said that he was like shooting his
scenes with him today and they're doing
Maryna like like why not man like and
I'm and I thought this show looked legit
interesting
yeah I gotta went for it I think it's
cute that he's got the dog because he
does that dog should realize like he's
all about you know rescue dogs as he
does a use Bert wards
dog chow yeah you really got it in for
robbing [ __ ] I'm trying to lure
you [ __ ] The Joker to beat him with a
crowbar
he's our [ __ ] childhood hero no I
love I love like the last ride stories
be like you know here's a guy there's
it's [ __ ] winter of his life who just
like I want to do one more heist one
last job one last mission one last time
I get a set engaged and so many like
makes his [ __ ] go like I'm here for that
and how many episodes they say it's on
CBS all access so if I had to guess I'd
excuse me I'd say like 13 between 10 and
13 Wow I mean I'm not like beat making a
joke but he's rather he's how old is he
13 episode commitment it's a lot to ask
of a guy this age you think it easily
get away really yeah Jesus could you
imagine like back to that grind of a
schedule that's well good for him he
wants a day obviously he wouldn't be
there and he clearly doesn't seem like
somebody needs the money because think
about it man he walked away from the
card so long ago and she he'd been
[ __ ] professor X for the last hundred
years
like the Picard thing must be like oh
this will be fun I get to go play in
this world again and I'm sure they're
paying him a [ __ ] king's ransom
seventy-nine
oh this has to be one episode long oh my
god let this guy rest for [ __ ] sake
yeah that was it we saw the entire
Picard and then trailer hope you liked
it um wow man good friend [ __ ] I hope
sucking at 79 people like we want to do
Silent Bob this series like just sign me
up push me around in a chair I'll be
saying nothing [ __ ] kidding me I
don't have to say [ __ ] a Silent Bob
now the other one know you probably be
dead at that point um that'd be crazy
McCarty I mean he's got to actually say
some [ __ ] to make his money I'm gonna
have to walk and everything that'd be
crazy Wow I can't wait to watch that
show actually like I'm washed in that I
watched the first few of the new show
which work goodbye my big beef with it
was like Jesus these Klingons look
expensive it was just way too much
makeup going on and stuff like that but
this I think I would really get into
because I do love the old-timer goes
back storylines I mean as an old-timer
now that's all I [ __ ] look alright I
have one more little thing before we get
to Marvel okay did you see the beautiful
day in the neighborhood trailer oh yeah
I mean god it was fun holy [ __ ] we all
know he would crush it but [ __ ] like
like he looked good in the one photo
they put out he put out a while ago but
you know it's it's Hanks can't escape
the fact that Hanks nor do you want to
and she no but my god did he channel mr.
Rogers it is it is the last scene in the
trailer that [ __ ] broke me when he's
sitting on the subway and like you know
the the like the the Benetton version of
the president like just [ __ ] black
Hispanic kids Asian kids whatever look
hey mr. Rogers and everybody starts
singing the [ __ ] theme song and I
just
[Music]
[Music]
that was me the last 10 seconds of that
[ __ ] trailer I can't go see the movie
I just can't do you think they cover did
you watch the documentary yeah
the documentary is [ __ ] astounding
but do you think they cover cuz I
remember correctly this story happens
way late in his life it happened only
like like 10 years ago or something that
the guy went to interview them and he
was like how do i interview Fred Rogers
and Fred Rogers opened his heart and
[ __ ] everything you see in the trailer
but I wonder if they'll cover the era
when he went to speak to Congress
because when I watched that in the
documentary like you know they put a
clip in there but then I went to the
Internet and watched the whole I was
like a year in it Fred Rogers at one
point I'm sure most people [ __ ] know
this if you've seen the documentary but
I hope they do in the movie because [ __ ]
it was just made for a movie like you
know the government was about to pull
funding of PBS and [ __ ] like that
because it was a dark corrupt government
that just wanted yeah yeah
this happened a long time ago it'll
never happen again so they were trying
to pull funding from PBS and I had a
bunch of people come in talk to the you
know the [ __ ] Senate the hill
whatever [ __ ] whoever says you can have
bunny congress on they had to walk up
steps just like that that [ __ ]
cartoon bill i'ma wherever the [ __ ] they
went so they're talking to a bunch of
people trying to say hypertrophy oh yes
trying to figure out like why why do we
give why do we [ __ ] pay him for public
public television [ __ ] this noise and he
gets up there and gives the most
eloquent beautiful [ __ ] speech that
still works today
it's [ __ ] timeless about how
important public funding and funding is
for public television and it's
something out of a movie the guy the guy
who's like who's the head of the
committee or whatever like literally in
the beginnings like all right Rogers
what do you got you know pulling up his
sleeves and like you're not gonna win
this one it's tailor-made and then mr.
Rogers just [ __ ] breaks with the
truth and all heart and [ __ ] it's like I
like to teach children how to have
access to their emotions because if we
can't understand who we are inside we
can't be good citizens outside and I'd
like to do with through songs so if I
can I'd like to tell you some of the
lyrics to the songs and he just starts
talking about how like some days you're
angry and some days you want to fight
some days you want to pout in some days
you want to bite but if you just sit
down and talk to your friends that maybe
you don't have to be angry again or
whatever the [ __ ] it was [ __ ] it give it
up that was awesome because even if you
were just making it up it all rhymes and
you could have just been freestyling for
all I knew but that didn't eat was that
what he said majesty Stalin how
impressive modern day mr. Roger
mr. Robbins his neighborhood but like at
the end of that like whatever eight
minutes it is which was all off the
[ __ ] K you didn't come with a speech
prepared he just says how much is gonna
talk to you about what we do and and the
[ __ ] like the muppet villain was like
you know what you just got your money it
really is a so tailor-made for me when
you watch it this happened in the real
[ __ ] world like you watch this
[ __ ] face slowly melt from like
- and he's he's beside himself at the
end he can't believe that this gentle
man [ __ ] talked him out of millions
of dollars but he's like you did it
Rogers you saved it it's [ __ ]
beautiful I hope they put down the flag
even if it's like that happening before
he met this guy and [ __ ] just go back
and show that moment that's why I
thought when they were on the subway I
was like oh [ __ ] maybe he's in New York
because they shot that show in
Pittsburgh and Pittsburgh fantasy that's
how we wound up with Betty aberlin who
was lady aberlin has been in so many of
our flex because we went to shoot Dogma
they're extras casting lady who was like
Betty Oberlin wants to come in
audition and I was like Daddy aberlin is
that like she related to lady aberlin
from mr. Rogers she is that is lady
aberlin and I was like she does not have
to audition she can have the part man's
royalty and she played the nun the one
that like Matt Damon as Loki is talking
her out of religion at the end and [ __ ]
like that so we have to put her in a
bunch of stuff she's in Jersey girl
which is his movie with her kill rose
here she's wonderful but she was there
ground zero for like Fred Rogers and she
wasn't in the documentary and they had
her in the documentary you know the
young footage of her and [ __ ] because
she's there the episode where they talk
about Kennedy's assassination she was
talking to Daniel tiger or something
like that
but I asked her why she was like why why
did they go to you for the documentary
and she said yeah I said why didn't you
do it she was like you can't capture
that man like she was like there's
nobody that could and you know she's
like I love Tom Hanks but like Fred
Rogers you you couldn't do him justice I
couldn't sit down and even try to relate
who he was what he meant to the culture
and stuff it is astounding she held him
and still holds him in the highest
[ __ ] regard that [ __ ] trailer is
tearjerker can do everytime I see like
mr. Rogers trending like no he's back no
they didn't learn some [ __ ] that I don't
want to know oh no oh [ __ ] I raised them
they raised him from the grave and [ __ ]
and he's like deal with this children
sometimes the Dead come back it's like
even after death mr. Rogers is helping
us that warms my heart and it dropped I
think like the Friday of comic-con no I
just I think it's after their jobs I
don't like Monday or some such [ __ ] was
after comic-con they stood clear
I don't know how time or space works man
I think it was Friday
maybe it's Monday it's all good can we
[ __ ] talk about Marvel now
[Applause]
Jesus Marvel just [ __ ] don't they
complain honestly was the weirdest not
weirdest but the most out of left field
never would have predicted it couldn't
see it coming never would have danced
that much had no idea that one was
coming I just thought that you know why
would they touch that there they were
during the future that's the past but oh
my god like it makes a lot of sense all
the sins and and I love that
according to Feige he was like yeah you
know more Hersh Allah he called us and
said he want to have a meeting and and
we didn't know what the meeting was
about
and we were hoping that it was gonna be
about what we hoped it was gonna be
about it's like if he walks in the door
and he says I wanna be blade and we said
that's what we wanted the meeting to be
about yes because when the double Oscar
winner says I want to be blade you say
yes yeah I think he's an amazing actor
but how weird man he will now have
played to Marvel characters right from
Luke Cage and so in some conceivable
world he could fight himself I think it
works I mean the Doctor Strange stuff
like it's all [ __ ] magic let's go
through a piece by piece it makes god
you're just [ __ ] going for everything
trying to get it done like I want the
anal to just slow man slow the Eternals
we got a lifetime together all right
they announced phase four and phase four
is ten different projects you have the
chart Nick I'll pull it up on my phone
yeah well I mean fate including it's my
wallpaper
we'll Wilkins was in there the whole
time come on man yeah recognize me
you've got a recognize and he was
sending me live updates because I was
the next panel and [ __ ] so I was getting
ready at home okay smoking that caviar
and so he was feeding me constant
[ __ ] updates and so he sent me oh it
was fantastic
he sent me the little chart here we go
okay ten of them number one block
starting in 2020 that is May first
twenty first god that's the next we got
to wait till May to get another Marvel
movie [ __ ] jerks
Black Widow let's discuss number one yay
yeah but we all knew this this is
already happening it kicks off phase
four mm-hmm but it's a story set in the
past likely set in Budapest the Budapest
they're always referring to let's
confirm those Budapest stories which
means Hawkeye overall at the ended as
well right yes along with Rachel Vice
David Harbor and David harbors playing
the [ __ ] anti he's like the red
Captain America what was he called red
soldiers I like that [ __ ] John
anybody know that a character's name red
Guardian well who said that [ __ ] a
man well done you earn your [ __ ]
stripes my friend red Guardian which is
the [ __ ] Russia the Russian
equivalents Captain America all that's
great I'm onboard but this is a story
set in the past and this is how they
kick off phase four so I can't imagine
that this is just like oh it's
unfinished business we just you know
they told us that [ __ ] phase three
ends with spider-man
mmm-hmm far from home face-fucking four
begins with this movie Black Widow does
that mean that Black Widow this [ __ ]
story set in the past is gonna have
significance not to the phase one two
and three
but to phase four in mind they've been
playing with some tongue trouble
shenanigans
so one never can tell this I mean since
it proceeds the eternal
one would imagine that has to play some
sort of role sudden maybe they reveal
they've been with us all along or
somesuch should I could they gotta tie
them together right because this happens
in man when's the Eternals happen
November so it's May June July August
September October November
it uh I counted they're gonna make the
Eternals happen and nobody's heard [ __ ]
about the Eternals this is like as this
is as unpress old as [ __ ] guardians
mm-hmm so they're they got to do some
[ __ ] seeding of the franchise it has
to occur in Black Widow and I'm not just
talking about like the end credits and
[ __ ] like I got to imagine like if
they're leading phase four with Black
Widow can't be about tying up old
storylines it's got to have something to
do with what's going forward you think
it could and don't give me that it could
[ __ ] yes James do you think you agree I
agree I concur
Scott here thank you I was just looking
for you to conquer but and also you know
Loki's got a tesseract has been
traveling back through time it is
entirely possible that he as another
member of a alien race that has been
mistaken for gods much like the Eternals
which are the Greek gods where the dads
guardians are the Norse gods could
somehow tie some of that [ __ ] together
that's the one that you know I'm look
I'm going for all these but that's the
one I'm least sold on is the Eternals
not like I'm like there's gonna suck but
like I have no familiarity if I remember
correctly there were only a like five
there were less than 20 issues of the
Eternals like it's it's this is deep
cuts [ __ ] Marvel not even like when
they announced guardians I'm like that
piece of [ __ ] like this is like one oh
yeah I think I remember seeing this at a
show in 95 on a wall for like three
blocks what the [ __ ] is this but this is
Jack Kirby Jack Kirby went back to
Marvel and kind of finished his New Gods
run and called that the Eternals more or
less and that's what we're getting and
that's a huge cast they did they brought
out all the Jolie's
every one of them took this stage
Angelina Jolie in this
kumail's in this mail Richard Madden is
playing Richard Richard Madden's the
king of the north right yep till they
until they cut his head off and
bodyguard
yeah and Brian Terry Henry now who's
that he was um he was Miles Morales is
dead the voice of Maz Morales is dead
in spite of who's he in real life when
he's not a cartoon he's in Atlanta he
was yeah okay he's great he's phenomenal
if that's this sorry fastest Alma's in
as well Salma Hayek is playing I had it
here I copy and pasted that [ __ ] she's
in it just well later names later Ajax
leader the Eternals yes all of these
characters you know you gotten funny
they gotta make us care about them quick
right in order to make this [ __ ] work
guardians we cared about quick because
hey it's tied into this [ __ ] somehow and
whatnot so they got tie this [ __ ] into
it somehow and the Eternals have been
around for like a red-hot minute mm-hmm
I don't even know if they're setting the
president of this is a story set in the
past but somebody pointed out that all
their colors represent the Infinity
stones then again those are just like
primary colors look it's red and yellow
and green and blue where do we get these
my Intel associate of the Infinity
Gauntlet or a box of Crayola what is it
he said
what'd he say and he referent he don't
call him the Eternals though did he
Celestials mmm the Celestials a part of
the Eternals you're just making [ __ ] up
now aren't you now we're in the Internet
[ __ ] yeah the Celestials in the Eternals
they need humans they're all the same
things they don't have the same colors
alright alright so there they're gonna
tie it in somehow they will they'll find
a way they gotta keep them stones alive
right I mean I know that story lines
done but still it's like you don't need
stones when you got rings my name
shang-chi and the legend of the ten ring
you're going too [ __ ] far we're going
in order that is it's not I'm doing the
[ __ ] children I'm doing
what a [ __ ] chart goddamnit and I
call you a newsman after the Eternals
in spring of 2021 this is where the plan
gets insidious it's not just in the
movie theaters now you have to get the
Disney Plus app because the story lines
are running through the series on Disney
Plus that Kevin Feige is overseeing and
they're all tied into the movie so this
isn't like a shield where there exist in
a Marvel Universe that the movies don't
seem to acknowledge at all these shows
are going to be integrated into the
movie storylines will carry through from
the movies into the series and then back
out into the next movie yeah yeah that
made me [ __ ] excited I was like oh my
god that's brilliant man like like so
that's next time your pirate a poster
well Juan division is next which is now
that has to also be set in the past
right because he [ __ ] died well it's
nuts in the past it is post vision I
mean Bettany I think will will be like
kind of in it but he's dead in one
division also the vision and Wan
division isn't about vision wanders
vision of what
she sees seashells by the seashore
wait are you just making this up you
read it what go ahead and explain it
again yeah [ __ ] does that tell me about
Wanda vision man I damn it are you
sounded like you knew some [ __ ] I just
want to know so visions not in what shoe
had your chance vision is not go star of
Wanda vision I think he will be in it in
memory and in sort of like she is the
most powerful witch on the [ __ ]
planet she can conjure versions of
vision back but not least is he gonna be
like six in [ __ ] Battlestar Galactica
like she sees him could very well be
only in her imagination and yeah but she
could she's powerful which he could
bring her back can't she just [ __ ]
remain he's a [ __ ] robot make him
again
but it's Paul Bettany innit he's in it
it's to explore the scarlet witch's
headspace after losing her boyfriend and
being dust for five years in the where
five years she was snapped away so she
comes back with he don't correct
because he died before this man right he
dies pre-snap and we don't think she's
just gonna make a new vision maybe she
does she [ __ ] better she's so
powerful man I rewatched endgame
recently with Muse in a hotel and [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] moment where she like
lands and she's like you took everything
from me this is so awesome because I
don't even know who you are oh my god
[ __ ] so he's the one who gets him to
launch the [ __ ] missiles yeah yeah
yeah she almost breaks where he's a
great fire yeah I was [ __ ] it open
just do it
kill me I'm the greatest Nike commercial
of all time
rain fire just do it swoosh I'm okay
then it's spring of 2021 which is right
around the same time these two things
are happening cuz I think it's not
[ __ ] up it's comes off Kevin Feige
[ __ ] scream [ __ ] winter soldiers
in 2020 you're in E in 2021 [ __ ]
dude this is it is not it is fault oh
you know what I went this way I don't
know how to read a graph [ __ ] he's never
wrong so it goes well if I go wrong I
was wrong Kevin read it wrong so it goes
like this yeah I thought it was going
like this a time line [ __ ] does this
don't we read left to right what the
[ __ ] all right so starts with [ __ ]
Black Widow then goes from May 20-22
fall of 2020 Falcon and Winter Soldier
yes we've know about this they kind of
talked about this before but will he be
cap that I think is the crux of what
that shows gonna be uh uh yeah that the
government doesn't want Sam Wilson to be
Captain America are you shittin me
that's the story do you know that sorry
yeah
you think why do you know that did they
say that that read it somebody wrote it
somebody wrote it put on the Internet
that's a [ __ ] good storyline instead
he got fitted for a new suit hmm so but
he's got the shield and they don't want
him to have it they want somebody else
to be Captain America and Zemo is bad
yes with the Basques they're putting the
[ __ ] pink mask on Zemo I was so
delighted to you that I [ __ ] was
texting with will Wilkins and he was
like zimos back and I wrote with the
mask and he wrote back [ __ ] yes
oh that was awesome all right so that's
what's gonna happen and I meant look I
was in for those guys but I'm [ __ ] in
I'm back for Zemo and a mask that's
[ __ ] phenomenal then we go to eternals
in November which is roughly the same
time well November who are in a movie
theater see the eternal so think about
it this show happens and then during the
show they could be running
promos for eternal so they're pushing
you back to the theater you go to the
theaters see that then November 20 22
February 20 21 is shang-chi and The
Legend of the ten rings this is exciting
for old school Marvel fans master of
Kung Fu apparently they're not going to
call him that but that's what he is
Shang she is the master of Kung Fu one
of Marvel's favored favorite 70s
characters not to mention a chance for
them to have their own Asian superheroes
yes a missed opportunity with Iron Fist
as we saw but they're not missing it
here
there was talk for years about whether
or not they could do this because his
origin the character's origin is tied up
with foo Manchu mm-hmm foo Manchu which
is owned by somebody else is like the
National features syndicate or whatever
so they for tried to extricate him but
they found a way to [ __ ] do it and
make us all happy by announcing that the
bad guy would be none other than the
real man ders not that not the guy was
Ben Kingsley one which to be fair was
fun no not even the guy Pierce one yeah
but like the actual a Tony Leung is
playing the actual [ __ ] Mandarin and
the ten rings you got to remember has
been there since the start of the Marvel
Universe [ __ ] him once Iron Man in the
desert he was kidnapped by the ten rings
and before he was Iron Man and stuff
Iron Man 3 they [ __ ] used the 10
rings as a front and stuff and there was
that little short after Iron Man you
know where he went to jail and [ __ ]
Ben Kingsley went to jail he ran into
Sam Rockwell and there was like there is
a real Mandarin so it took him a minute
but they probably got to the real
Mandarin so this is gonna be [ __ ]
huge right
I mean Marvel doing a kung fu movie [ __ ]
I'm all about that [ __ ] then in the
spring of 2021 we go to Wan Division
then from Wan division which is spring
at 2021 to May 2021 so roughly around
the same time again the series happens
and then while you watch them want a
vision they're like coming soon Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of [ __ ]
madness
they've announced this is their first
real horror title they're gone for scott
derrickson who directed dr. strange also
directed some horror movies prior to
this so he's got the absolute right
sensibility for it and they've announced
as my man said before that uh Scarlet
Witch is going to be in it too this
sounds what we rented a theater but we
will to be sure this movie sounds
absolutely [ __ ] tremendous we don't
know [ __ ] about it by the title
yeah but multiverse of madness like that
means there is a multiverse and there is
they said and [ __ ] Doctor Strange
there was a multiverse
yeah and Mysterio wasn't just blowing
smoke up his ass there actually is a
[ __ ] multiverse yeah it does also
lead me to believe that it when scott
derrickson says this is gonna be the
first Marvel horror movie that we may
never see the New Mutants it's true yeah
or it'll be on streaming or something
but it it does not well maybe they mean
the first Marvel Studios I guess but Fox
now belongs to Disney which belongs to
everything so somebody's announcement
were there like congratulations to
Disney on beating Disney for the top
spot as Disney sits by and watches and
Disney celebrates after Doctor Strange
we jump up to also spring of 2021 for
Loki yes we heard about previously Tom
Hiddleston returning and the plot is
Loki tripping through time with the
tesseract the one we saw disappear from
2012 from endgame isn't that [ __ ] up
so like an endgame their biggest [ __ ]
movie ever they ceded their TV show like
that's how far out ahead they are man
and I remember when that happened yeah I
was like hey they didn't tie that up
they're like that's the show [ __ ]
so [ __ ] I'll watch that and you know
[ __ ] like it's smart to because like
Loki's gonna be set in the past and and
it's Loki from you know phase 1 2 & 3 so
there'll be lots of nice familiarity
from the old phases before as we're
heading into Worlds of Eternals and
stuff like that as the new kids are
coming they're still supported by the
veteran players you know and with
storylines that tie into the [ __ ] that
they made us fall in love with over the
course of 10 years is real [ __ ] smart
plan man
insidious is [ __ ] yeah I mean it doesn't
feel as if though at least from what
we're gathering that phase 4 is building
to an event the way that like phases 1 2
& 3 built you know just doesn't seem as
if it's you know the Infinity Gauntlet
saga is over like we're not doing that
again which I'm actually kind of fun
with unless this is part 1 of the build
to Galactus I mean we know that he
referenced Fantastic Four on that stage
nothing specific but so you know if
you're gonna build to another big bad
who better than the world eater himself
and in their hands in the hands of
Marvel Studios alright so summer 2021
back on the Disney Plus channel we get
what if animated what if featuring all
the voices of the Marvel Studios
performers so [ __ ] you know cumber
[ __ ] he'll be doing the voice of
Doctor Strange like a [ __ ] rat well is
coming back to do Peggy Carter what if
she was Captain America's storyline
what if of course for those that you
know if you don't follow this sort of
thing was Marvel's comic of hey here's
the continuity you know here are stories
where we [ __ ] with the continuity right
which is funny because it's like here
are made up stories and here are made up
stories about the made up stories that
they had to single out separately so
that fans of the made up stories
wouldn't be mad about
new made-up stories it was Elseworlds
before there was an elsewhere long
before how nice man if I could do it in
Kevin Feige of course the genius peon
let's bring that in and Jeffrey Wright
is voicing the watcher yes Oh ah - what
a great voice he's God he's amazing oh
my god so then after what if still on
the Disney plus Channel
looks like that summer is what if and
then the fall they launch Hawkeye with
Jeremy Renner and a based on what we saw
there doing the Kate Bishop story but
somebody said this takes place in the
past did you hear anything I didn't know
I would hope it takes place you want
next after end game totally but somebody
was like yeah but he was Ronin and then
again but yeah but at the end of endgame
he's not Ronin anymore hey he had his
family back in [ __ ] starts being a rock
star cutting cheap commercials I hope
it's future Hawkeye not past talking and
then the last one was for love and
thunder and for this number one - eco
ytt coming back of course number two
Natalie Portman coming back as Jane and
they're gonna turn her into Lady throw
they're doing the Mighty Thor storyline
from Jason Aaron run Aaron run and
apparently letting Lady Thor into the
mix what is that I know now it's part of
continuity man so that's pretty darn
sweet man what was great truckin and
Valkyrie is still the reigning king of
Asgard and she will get herself a queen
they enough that yeah yeah the first
like out LGBT character and then well
the universe is gonna be Valkyrie wow
man I didn't hear that yeah god that's
smart and good
it is both of those yes some [ __ ] is
just I mean I don't know how to call it
just [ __ ] what a masterstroke that was
yeah and so you know Feige also said
that we are gonna get a black panther to
is coming Guardians 3 is coming Captain
Marvel T was coming Fantastic Four is
coming and then her Sheila with [ __ ]
blade hat on is also coming
that's boy what a [ __ ] what a heady
yeah mixture of what was just gonna be
like oh the Russos are coming to do a
panel and it's just kind of gonna be
like you know goodbye to marvel thanks
for phase 3 guys it was amazing
turns into oh [ __ ] we're gonna tell you
all the [ __ ] things and make you
happy to be alive for the next [ __ ]
two years man
here's your reason not to die [ __ ]
love Marvel [ __ ] man thoughts on all of
that I was honestly I'm not disappointed
but I shocked that if Fantastic Four is
not part of phase 4 I mean but I guess
it's phase 5 that's or if that also
might not be all of phase 4 no I think
they told us the truth they lived up to
what they said about the other ones like
you know what I'm saying they were never
like I am Wow here's the secret one we
never told you
d23 yeah it's true d23 I wonder what
they'll tell us there yeah Marvel's
gonna have announcements more than that
they showed us how much more dick are
they hiding man oh my god this is people
that can only [ __ ] just the tip less
they'd [ __ ] kill whoever they engage
with because there's just so much [ __ ]
dick it never ends and it's [ __ ]
thick and luscious and even though we
can't take it we're like keep going
[ __ ] that would be amazing if they
announced the mothership man god
[ __ ] in what's going on you steal
somebody's crutch
speaking of dick Oh cuz he stole a
crutch that's funny
um who what's the story with the crutch
fractured toe she wants a sound crutch
oh my god right on how did you fracture
to tell krav maga what the [ __ ] that's
some fighty [ __ ] right did you kick
somebody and that they they heard as bad
as your foot they felt bad but that they
hurt your foot with their body yeah they
broke your toe with their head crutch
delivery what is this I just signed two
of these and this one says this is for
me who's is this a big league pillow and
explain it's pillow made of gum sorry
pillow made of gum big league chew man
they made [ __ ] pillows oh my god
they're personalized pillows designed
for kids to dream big this is awesome
and I get to keep this one [ __ ] I
check that out man big league pillows
ladies and gentlemen very nice thank you
leaves you guys alright did we hit all
that how to sign this one in black man
do you have like a white marker or
something somebody gave me a black
marker to sign a black shirt and I mean
I hate to be this guy but
now you got something they might write
on black cloth that's all the news baby
that's all the news Marc disseminated
all the news there is to print give it
up for mark barnard lady Alice the
breads not gonna show up
grim Jack let's talk about that - yeah
[ __ ] the Russo brothers announced to
do and Grimm Jack oh I'm always talking
about how grim Jack could be an awesome
series they [ __ ] apparently grew up
with it as well and they're also
announced that they're doing battle of
the planets man that's [ __ ] nuts nuts
man [ __ ] could you imagine
after The Avengers movies they could
literally probably just be like we're
gonna raise the Titanic and people be
like [ __ ] a man like is Iron Man
coming
speaking of Titanic yes endgame did
finally officially become the
highest-grossing movie of all time
[Applause]
after they like found two million
dollars lying around we're all so happy
because all of us get to participate in
the profits and so that's why we're so
happy some mega-corporation made a bunch
of money we don't get I don't know why I
have a rooting interest in that sort of
thing but I was very delighted that that
happened and you know yeah there was a
period where it was like oh they're off
by a lot but in finals as they're
bringing in tallies of the money I guess
they found a bunch of yeah found a bunch
of loot there look how much - how much
what's the difference we found that but
Cameron James Cameron actually did put
out this actually kind of super chill
and like it's a picture of Iron Man with
a little [ __ ] glowy things from
Avatar like landing on his armor and
just congratulations guys for being the
number one movie I guess you can't be
king of the world for more than a decade
or some [ __ ] like that right on I don't
know what to say to that
that's just [ __ ] way above my pay
grade people that have made billions of
[ __ ] dollars talking to each other
through [ __ ] newspapers is like
that's just so [ __ ] huge but I'm sure
he's like enjoy it for now because you
know it's pretty close right to what the
record was on avatar so they could
potentially right before avatar to
release avatar 1 again catch another 20
to 50 and then [ __ ] they're number
one again and then [ __ ] Avengers is
like hold on
buggin end ish game the Edition but yeah
now they're just [ __ ] like fighting
themselves I think we attached the
Snyder cut [ __ ] yeah man it's that's for
whatever reason I was kind of happy
about that the fact that that did break
a record seemed a little convenient but
hey whatever most happy endings are
right I'm not questioning I'm not saying
they made that [ __ ] up no we would never
I'm just happy it happened in shape yeah
apparently there's more news anymore
news that we forgot from [ __ ] San
Diego or rather he forgot from San Diego
[ __ ] cats was it hold on one second
JJ Abrams what what what JJ Abrams is
going to be directing 8 hours ago
somebody said that JJ Abrams is gonna be
directing Superman somebody checked this
check his math JC is this accurate yeah
somebody just said oh [ __ ] yeah in the
back
what the [ __ ] Laura Bowman what one [ __ ]
a job this guy knew and you didn't what
website is this for reading off of
Warner Brothers didn't go to Comic Con
what's the [ __ ] news somebody pull it
up who's got the news you get to be on
the show well the website is this we're
meeting often come up here into the
light come into the light coming to the
light come up here it's over here about
JC I guess you come up here what's this
I'm getting it on cosmic book news that
I don't yeah yeah it's not variety but
this smells like rumour Patrol did you
get me some cosmic book news where else
did you is that where you heard same
story that's truth we know that jay-z
has signed a deal with tell me the
Superman Green Lantern shape yeah move
on sit down
JJ wants to tackle but still he wants to
tackle Superman Superman script years
ago yeah yeah yeah nobody wants to make
that I stand by my hastily cobble
together news I'm sorry I came down boy
I flipped on you holy hard
[ __ ] first that guy Mike who came last
through time as the [ __ ] wife was all
like you should do them all you know
[ __ ] shut up Mike the last oh yeah you
still carrying that cross around because
he's [ __ ] a month ago man I have one
half-ass job alright man so now we got
the part of the show ladies and
gentlemen where we open it up to you
folks hey this was also a gift for me
who gave me the hat wherever they're
from big league oh my god you're the
gift that keeps on giving where can they
get the big league pillows at so what
Big League pillows calm big-league
pillows calm and then let's add as dope
it's an r2d2 if you can't see what he
feels metal it lights up its eliminated
it might have died it charges with USB
it was on the whole time while you guys
were yapping there is [ __ ] dope yeah I
mean I wear it backwards but then in the
night people be like he [ __ ] really
likes art exactly that's argue is really
far away you could act they're actually
available at galaxies agita exclusive
you get this a gallon you fancy they're
available in our joint depot at the joy
Depot is that where you got this no I
make those as well
you make this and you sell them at
drawer Depot correct so Disney buys
these from you yeah I'm really not
supposed to talk about it
but uh yeah maybe you didn't have to
talk about it nobody liked to pull that
[ __ ] out of you what's magic about that
is we rarely like all of us give Disney
our money we rarely meet anybody who
takes some away from them you're a
unicorn man that's awesome man
congratulations
that's that sweet and that's very
[ __ ] sweet all right here we go
open it up to Q&A JC the fine proprietor
of this here establishment not to
mention what was your official title I
call you the post supervisor but I don't
know if I'm right about that
it's assistant editor that it sounds
like your job is way bigger than an
assistant editor I'm an editor folks I
like to cut the movies that I shoot and
stuff but I'll be honest with you I
don't know how to even load the footage
into the avid to cut with it so without
JC I'd be [ __ ] lost JC loads all that
footage and stuff and then as we get
closer and closer to reality to finalize
him taking it from my editing laptop
into the real world there were people
are well they don't cut negative anymore
but you know going through the final
process of printing and [ __ ] like that
he's been the guy my right hand
throughout the entire process
we just locked picture and sound the
other day the movie's officially [ __ ]
done and delivered to the folks that
financed it and stuff and like he made
it all possible Thank You JC and
mind you he did it while he [ __ ] runs
this bar like every damn day
so like he was spinning many plates at
once but never once dropped ours and now
like we're done and I love the movie and
you know I can't wait to share with
people couldn't share with people unless
you did what you do so thank you
alright so JC's picking somebody to go
first we are giving away let's talk
about we're giving away point oh [ __ ] I
forgot that
yes we're giving away 40 X tickets are
the words the X tickets folks from our
good friends at 40 X Brett Deacon got us
another round we got three sets we got
three sets three sets if you've not seen
a movie in the 40s experience the chair
comes alive and terrifies you for two
hours straight gives you a massage but
shoots water and smells into your face
it is [ __ ] tremendous you see a big
action movie in it it'd be absolutely
[ __ ] amazing so we're giving away
three sets of tickets two tickets apiece
also what comes with it is this here
this week's poster for the show from
Nate naked dolls artwork ladies
gentlemen The Dark Knight Returns we've
got three posters that me and Mark and
native signs so they'll go with the
tickets as well and we also have an
adora and the distance pin thanks for
the good folks of comixology for letting
me steal them and make off with them and
and one other pin set that I got the
good folks at think geek gave me this
commemorative Star Trek thing to
commemorate like the 50th anniversary
ds9 and
30th anniversary of the next-gen finale
and like whatever that was the [ __ ] but
it's three pins that will give away to
one lucky winner or you can break up the
set and get one Pete penny we could do
that too diplomacy mom all right so
first question asker has been chosen by
JC what's your name my friend my name is
Alex I'm Howard z-boy you're from Jersey
give it up for Alex from New Jersey what
part I live I grew up in Bayonne but I
live down the shore and I'm actually
gonna see you in a few weeks at the
Atlantic island Playhouse but you're
gone there I'm actually an actor there
oh [ __ ] you read the first seven my
house I'll be working while you're doing
your thing hopefully I can Hey
well maybe you can be involved in the
reading of cheeks we got a lots of parts
to read for those who were like what the
[ __ ] are you guys talking about yeah
First Avenue Playhouse in Atlanta
Collins New Jersey is town over from
where I grew up I grew up in Highland
landok is like three miles away it's the
next town so bigger town than ours in
fact it is a town whereas Highlands is
are technically a borough
Lana Collins is an actual town so that
was where the movie theater is for you
know the Atlantic islands twin cinema
which is now a multiplex they have
they're in town the First Avenue
Playhouse which is just dessert theater
and has been for [ __ ] 100 200 years
at this point so when I was a kid you'd
go see a [ __ ] show and eat some cake
and [ __ ] when we were going through
clerks trying to make clerks I went into
the First Avenue Playhouse talked to the
owner Joe Bagnall and say hey man we're
gonna make a movie can we have auditions
here can we hold auditions in the
Playhouse and stuff and he was like what
do you mean movie and I tried to explain
indie film to him and he said all right
yeah totally come on as long as we can
bring in actors from the Playhouse to
audition for the movie so please that
that would help me cuz I didn't know any
actors and so so we held auditions there
guys where we found Brian and Marilyn so
Dante and and Veronica and a bunch of
other people a Joe who runs the theater
owns the theater is in the movie he's
the guy at the counter when the cats
taking a [ __ ] his wife Donna Jean was
the the customer the Randall gets into
it with where
he's like I don't appreciate your ruse
ma'am like that lady at the corner as
well as the guy who gives the [ __ ]
ticket the citation all these cats came
for them first to happen to play us so
theaters been around for like a hundred
years as I said but they've fallen on
financially I guess harder times tough
to maintain to keep it up so there was
an article in one of our local papers
from back home and I was like oh [ __ ] we
can raise money for these cats easily so
I came up with the idea of me and Ernie
O'Donnell let's do a fundraiser and
we'll use the clerk's three script that
we're never gonna make and read it out
loud so people could hear what the movie
wasn't and we put the tickets that like
they were premium they're like honored
bucks or something but they went [ __ ]
fast so we wound up doing two shows
we're only gonna do one show cuz we
didn't think it would sell out but it
sold out so fast like [ __ ] it let's do
another show so when all said and done I
think we raised 20,000 bucks for the
theater and stuff and so on what is the
August 3rd and 4th or 4th and 5th 3rd
and 4th August 3rd and 4th August
seconds my birthday I'll be 49 I'll fly
out to New Jersey thank you fly back to
the land of my birth to the [ __ ] City
my birth will to the town of my birth
Red Bank and [ __ ] and then well know
then I'll go to Atlantic islands which
is not the town of my birth because I
was born in read-back so that is the
town of my birth highlands this town I
was raised in but Atlantic was just a
town I went to a lot so going back to a
town I went to a lot to do the
fundraiser reading the script out loud
to set one once on a Saturday night and
once at a Sunday moon or a Friday night
and a Saturday afternoon I forget what
it is
I honestly you you're like I don't
[ __ ] know Joe Joe hasn't told me yet
what I think it's like yeah these two
separate Saturday and Sunday so it's
gonna be a good time we're gonna read
that script because I'll never make that
script that's a very depressing version
of clerks 3 not the way I want to end
those things anymore
or end that story I want to take one
more bite at that Apple and stuff and I
had that guy I've got a much better
story that I won't tell a better place
to leave my characters at for the rest
of their lives right now you know
they're trapped in the convenience store
which is what they really wanted but you
know then we went to black and white and
they were like ah [ __ ] so they were kind
of [ __ ] trap
I gotta deliver a matter I got to put
him in a place a happily ever after
because those two characters gave me so
[ __ ] much on their backs I've
traveled the [ __ ] world so I got to
go everywhere Dante and Randall are
still stuck at the convenience store so
I got to get him out of the convenience
store and the original script for clerks
three was too depressing you know people
like I remember people rather than be
like dude it's really great but you
remember clerks was a comedy right so so
I do have a different story I want to
tell and so I think I'm gonna pursue
that anyway we're gonna read the old
script at the first time to play house
and you're an actor there how [ __ ]
awesome what are you doing out or did
you go to comic-con I did how awesome
was it it was great had you ever been
before
yes right on how often do you go all the
time I try every year if I can I
actually spoke to you at all eh a few
years back telling you about that I
thought you should take one of your
scripts and bring it to stage and funny
enough you are okay hey man you planted
a seed and [ __ ] but I didn't here until
years later when you wrote tusk I said
oh that sounds great maybe you should do
it as a stage play and you said no it's
gonna be a movie but I mean does good
totally don't get me started but it
could work as a musical you know that
outfit is easy to do once we figured it
out and never look [ __ ] cool on stage
right like kind of like the Audrey - now
I'm thinking like every time you talk to
this dude he gives you an idea that you
will then taken and not pay them money
yes you should not keep telling him yeah
give me more ideas what questions what
if yeah I always love that series and
also else world and they announce that
they're gonna do
Superman red Sun red Sun I'm sorry an
animated version have you guys read
what-ifs if you were going to write a
what if either of you room to write a
what-if story using any characters
Marvel or DC or what story would you
tell I have a [ __ ] immediate answer
but I don't you go first no I can't
we're working on something oh okay
but let's see something I hate that and
again you could do Marvel DC or any
property ok want to tell a what-if story
if you want to change the history that
we know of the story we love what would
you do oh yeah I got one go Bruce Wayne
double-oh-seven
I think that if you if you pretended
that after the wings are killed rather
than raise Bruce Wayne in in Wayne Manor
Alfred takes him back to England and
Alfred was a [ __ ] spy and what do
they do when you're like raised by a spy
and you're an orphan in that he joined
the [ __ ] military he'd get all the
training and he would be absorbed into
[ __ ] the James Bond world and you
know you can have the Joker be the head
of smear experiment whatever the [ __ ]
that was SMERSH that would become
Spectre but you can absolutely play all
of the [ __ ] Batman rogues galleries
as if they were big bads and James Bond
movies Bane could be like a jaws
character yeah for sure and all things
like that but just just that idea you
get all the gadgets Alfred is his cue
Commissioner Gordon is his em like it
all kind of rather neatly ports over you
just need the rights to [ __ ] James
Bond to make that work and I don't have
those
money and that's what I do [ __ ] I didn't
think of anything in the time that you
were talking I'm just not that
imaginative let me see I instantly I'm
like Batman but I shouldn't you just did
Batman hmm hmm what if
my brain hurts
[ __ ] I broke him
yeah god well Comic Con broke him you
just buried it do this oh my let me I
know I came by thing I can get one no
what if Jays a bob were in the MCU I'd
be so rich stories would be good too but
[ __ ] the money what they what if your
parents names was Thomas and Martha
Feige and Matthew were Kevin Feige I
mean look business I'm not advocating
this and I'm sure it's been done a
number of different ways but if again
shouldn't be a feature or some such [ __ ]
but you know I can't get away from it I
wanted to get away from Batman but
you're gonna go to Batman do it like
what if his parents don't die what
happens to him what if he became a real
piece of [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
like [ __ ] maybe like his parents have
to die in order for him to become the
noble person that he becomes right
because maybe if not he just winds up
being a spoiled rich kid and [ __ ] like
that and turns into the guy who [ __ ]
chokes the life out of Gotham is
responsible for all the [ __ ] evil
isn't that Donald Trump put something
like that like you know [ __ ] Bruce
Wayne as the bad guy and who'll take him
on but a [ __ ] defiant clown but that
sounds you know like like the Joker but
that's what the Joker trailer kind of
looks like right like he's standing up
with the city or for the city in the
beginning he's Bernie Goetz yeah to some
degree wow that's a matron reference it
is but it's for the children
yeah I explained that quick Bernie Goetz
was a subway vigilante subway
everything's just a New Yorker just a
dude like riding the subway who had
gotten picked on one too many times and
eventually like was carrying a gun and
just like blue [ __ ] away on the
subway train didn't kill anybody you're
just really critically wounded or
something I I remember this was like 19
81-82 or something but now it was I
remember when this story this was on the
news and we grew up in the New York area
he grew up in New York I grew up in New
Jersey so it was on the news all the
time
and I remember like hearing them
constantly say the subway vigilante and
I was like did he wear a mask because
that was my only reference to [ __ ]
vigilante was Batman and he was like
they were using the word properly yeah
boy that one sad and dork I forgot about
all that was crazy sorry very
politicized remember that yeah and then
event yeah those are two really I like I
think I like his better than mine but
still two fairly decent answers to a
great question you win give it up for
him go you get the tickets you get the
poster you get a pin and you get one of
another pin you get to take all that
back to Jersey man I'll see you when we
do the show man good to meet you thank
you all right Jay see who we got next
who's the next victim
I got a sideshow that's that can we
cross over yeah cross over we'll do a
little more syndrome somebody get me a
miracle hey man what's your name
rich what is it rich Rach like I'll
Google rich rich like I'm [ __ ] rich
[ __ ] give it up for s man how are you
I'm great how are you guys doing good I
have a two-part question
fire away I'd like to know Kevin yes
would you like to smoke a ball after the
show yeah always but generally at home
by myself okay but I appreciate the
[ __ ] offer yeah I've gotten so much
[ __ ] weed I'm good
but one day when I don't have weed I'm
gonna come looking for you like you
still have that bowl here I'm here all
right guys my question is I know you're
both Star Wars fans you know Darth
Vader's story the way George Lucas did
it would be your guys's take forget the
prequels how would you make Darth Vader
become Darth Vader ooh
oh [ __ ] I know nobody ever asked me that
ever how would you do it Darth Vader get
to be Darth Vader
well I remember how Drazen I remember
yeah I remember when I was a kid being
so excited about the future of Darth
Vader because I don't where to [ __ ] out
red it must have been in Starlog but
Lucas did an interview somewhere where
he talked about like how Darth Vader
became Darth Vader and he was like he
was fighting Ben Kenobi on top of a
[ __ ] volcano when he fell in and that
captured my imagination I was like oh my
god and then Lucas was like we're done
with after Return of the Jedi and
suddenly there was no hope of ever
seeing that and I was like [ __ ] that
would have been so metal and then the
prequels happened and then we did see it
and I was like okay no it was good I
like that [ __ ] that was cool is that to
me fulfilled a lifelong dream of like he
[ __ ] did what I read years ago it was
[ __ ] in a volcano that took him out
so I'll always have that in my head
because I heard that since I was kid
volcano gotta take him to Darth Vader
now if I divorce myself from that and
don't have to be a volcano change the
whole prequels what would you guys do
with the whole Vader story I think he's
[ __ ] up because Kenobi like [ __ ]
hacked him within an inch of his life
it's not like him like my legs are
burnin [ __ ] yeah
it's like a [ __ ] you ever see that
one video the YouTube clip where
somebody like took a new hope and they
made the [ __ ] lightsaber fight
between Darth Vader and Ben Kenobi that
could be with modern special effects and
[ __ ] like that if it was they were just
hacking the [ __ ] out of each other and
[ __ ] he just got the better of him and
just like too so it was all done by Ben
Kenobi and battle and [ __ ] then when
they [ __ ] meet each other years later
on the Death Star he's like I'm gonna
kill the [ __ ] out of you old man
so I would go with that never mind this
[ __ ] falling into volcano should not
know about the podracing origin stuff
but I know that [ __ ] in my hands like
Kenobi would have been the one that
fuckabish
you could also steal from Marvel and be
like the mask came off and he was
beautiful and never needed it whatsoever
the Doctor Doom approached and [ __ ] but
I still like the [ __ ] up on I'll never
forget seeing like that little clip of
him in Empire Strikes Back with the
helmet off when I was a kid like what
the [ __ ] like it never I thought he was
a robot never occurred to me he was a
[ __ ] up person under in a [ __ ] like
that
it's amazing you how would you change
Darth Vader
I just wouldn't make the prequels
[Applause]
honestly it's because he was such a
perfect character the less you know
about him the better right like all I
need to know is oh he was a Jedi you
know like your father and he you know
succumb to the dark side and blah blah
blah I don't need that [ __ ] I need the
little glimpse of the goddess looking
ahead and that's [ __ ] scary I don't
want to know how Darth Vader gets to be
Darth Vader I just want to be Darth
Vader you know like I don't need to know
how the Joker gets to be the Joker I
just wanted to be the joke like like
sometimes I think the desire on our
parts you know occasionally is viewers
and occasionally a story telling us to
like oh no no but this part this part
should be [ __ ] rad and it's never as
rad as it is in our heads you know like
we are feeling I don't need to know how
Hannibal Lecter gets to be [ __ ]
Hannibal Lecter I don't want to invite
some [ __ ] faces off so like I'd the
desire that I might have is a
fan to see like the prequels I would
absolve myself of that [ __ ] as a
filmmaker just like you know what these
three great one do three more after that
great going backwards almost never works
almost never works except for like rope
one I like more now it's actually really
good yeah you did it man take your
goddamn winner thank you my man put a
glass in the bar and I was about to fill
it but he wants it signed oh well I was
ready to play Tom Cruise and [ __ ]
cocktail when I pour rain yeah because
that bar stays in business where one
dude makes one drink for half a [ __ ]
hour think about it she'd be chic if it
was modern-day [ __ ] Tom Cruise he
would dive headfirst into a bunch of
bottles with the camera roll and say you
know with some hey man what's your name
names Chris Chris give it up for Chris
[Applause]
what can we do you for it yes well what
got this going was I read your your kind
of self-help tough [ __ ] okay the book
freaking loved it thank you
mild like an insane person when I read
it you I enjoyed I was in public right
man but my question was you ever hear
the book on tape version well I mean the
audio I heard it on tape actually yeah
that was the best way to do it it had
more [ __ ] in it in the audio version
than in the book cuz I got to read the
book we should read it based on your new
knowledge that's hopefully next if
there's one time another message my
question was to both of you when I was
young I used to read
Spidey stories with Marvel and Electric
Company yes and you guys both have kids
and I have a child as well and I was
wondering if you guys were gonna write a
comic book for kids what would be the
kind of the moral or the thing you'd
want to teach in the comic book
based on being parents now wow I just
did that so I think for for me it's I
love the idea that courage is not the
absence of fear but it's acting while
you're afraid despite it you know the
idea that being brave doesn't mean that
you don't feel that you don't you're not
afraid of stuff we're all afraid of [ __ ]
but what what makes you a hero and
anybody can be hero he's doing the thing
even though you're afraid of it and I
think that the stories that I think we
all love the stories that I think all
resonate with us are not about people
who don't feel that [ __ ] but it's about
the people who do it anyway
you know and that I think is it's real
world hero it's like you know if you're
a [ __ ] fireman you signed up knowing
you were gonna have to walk into a
burning building you know the act of
heroism there isn't actually doing the
thing that you said you would do he was
signing up to do it to begin with you
know like it's you made that choice and
now you're just following through on the
choice you made and and I love that idea
of teaching children it's okay to be
afraid it's okay to doubt yourself a
little bit but what makes you awesome
what makes you hero is doing it anyway
done that that's [ __ ] good I don't
know I have a kid and if I was gonna
impart the [ __ ] that I impart to her in
a comic book character like it would be
like can you [ __ ] bring your dishes
upstairs all right let me say I think of
the [ __ ] that I've tried to impart like
to adults for the last few years doing
all the shows and [ __ ] and I guess you
know kids are just you know adults to be
little adults in training so I guess I
would just kind of modify the same
message which is there's two paths as
far as I see it there's creation and
destruction and destruction is [ __ ]
always crowded because anybody could
break [ __ ] down it's easy to [ __ ] to
destroy ways to destroy than it is to
create creating some takes an investment
of yourself part of yourself you
risk ridicule or rejection by taking the
creation path but so [ __ ] far more
rewarding and wide-open you know [ __ ]
the destruction path so [ __ ] crowded
because anybody can [ __ ] do it and
it's fun making [ __ ] is a thousand times
more fun and there's always room to do
it because not everyone will try it not
everybody wants to not everybody has an
Entenmann's stuff like that so if you
have that remotely in your DNA if you
feel that call that Muse muses call not
Jason Mewes ignore his call but [ __ ]
the call of the muse lean into it if I
was gonna be doing some book for a kid
comic book for a kid it would have to be
about that about I'm leaning into
imagination and [ __ ] like that but I you
know if I had an idea for a kid thing I
would have done a long [ __ ] time ago
when I had a kid particularly I had his
kids book I wanted to write all
throughout Harley's childhood and I
still haven't written it and she's
[ __ ] 20 so yeah I don't I don't know
it's weird as much as I love all the
[ __ ] from childhood and carried it into
my adulthood even when I wrote comics I
wasn't thinking about kids like they
were not the audience at that point it
was mostly people my age and stuff I
guess yoga hosers was the closest I got
to writing for kids and everyone hated
me for it and stuff so I I don't I don't
know that I'd be the one to do it but if
I was that's what it would be about for
sure it would be it'd be about making
stuff
my superhero kid would have to hoard my
superhero character would have to make
stuff in order for those powers to kind
of work I liked your story I thought
that was [ __ ] to open created this
book thank you really cool the coolest
thing that I've shown the Internet today
was the guy who just got casted
shengqi's Seema Lou I think he's hmm
years ago years I mean he hip he posted
or he retweeted the tweet that he had
sent to Marvel like you know almost a
year year and a half ago
it was like I want to be your shang-chi
and like it was a Canadian actor who
like dead like tiny movies he was on
Kim's groceries yeah yes
Kim's convenience tiny things but it
became this like hey if C mu could do it
you can do it to shoot your shot like
just air your [ __ ] dream job into the
world like just put the positive energy
out there just looking at all these
people just kind of using that as a like
oh maybe all you got to do or the first
step is saying it out loud you know like
we always like the other hopes and we
have our dreams and sometimes we tell
our friends and our family but it's you
know closely-held pushes sometimes she's
got to shut that [ __ ] from the rafters
and maybe just putting the energy into
the world will bring a little bit of it
back to you you know and like not for
nothing I also sigma boosted the tweet
that i put out on like 2017 where
sometimes like a what Marvin would like
to write and I said blade so like hey
Marvin thanks to that I've been at this
a while loving on that blade look if you
if you were to even get close to that
job if you got that job I don't want to
help right just put me in the movie
right Kevin Smith as a character and
they can [ __ ] kill me in the first
three seconds but put my [ __ ] ass in a
Marvel movie please please they sent my
name I want more now on FaceTime it [ __ ]
those won't be on camera look at the
camera look Stan Lee cameo you get
killed in every Marvel movie I would
take that if they're like we'll put you
in the Marvel movies just to mock you
and destroy you and I was like done you
oh my god be great what a great question
what a weak answer for me but a great
question for Mark you when take your
[ __ ] god damn pleasure man okay then we
had something sitting on here it said
please offer these to anyone in the
audience who would like one thanks at
this is what are they immortal error
stickers yeah
explain jump up into the spot here JC
will give you a mic and so we can
promote because goddamnit
this all begins with comic books JC is
racing his ass around the front he'll
get to second what's your name there
young camper names ed hey everyone give
it up for ad man Edie apparently is
doing something that very few people
think to do anymore make a [ __ ] comic
book is that right I'm making a comic
book I just published it about two weeks
ago Kickstarter's up right now it has
seven more days to go and right now I'm
just trying to put it out in the world I
was walking around comic-con wearing all
my own merch so I was a walking
billboard got noticed by a few people
that said hey I follow you on twitter I
follow you on Instagram so that was
pretty amazing just to be noticed and of
course I said oh you notice me here have
a free comic book so I was handing him
out anybody who wanted them so I have
stickers I want to give everybody in
here hopefully you guys check out the
comic book and enjoy it and I just want
to spread it around as much as possible
how can I really good man there's a guy
being he's taking the path of creation
not destruction man we're gonna leave
these right here everyone grab some on
your way out when you're grabbing your
[ __ ] don't forget we'll break them up
into three piles they'll be one over
here cats can grab and then there's I'm
sorry I'm walking everybody through my
instructions and then one over there
grab some stickers on your way out
support a [ __ ] artist man well done
well done it alright thank you guys
always inspired by you guys I usually
when I run here my podcast to run to
keep my mind off the heat and the
horrible miles I'm running and just
constantly inspiring creators and it's
always keeping me going so kind of
pushed me through the whole process
because you find out you think oh it's
so easy I'm gonna write a comic book not
easy and you have to fall you have to
fight through a lot of difficulties and
just keep pushing on and now you know
eventually hold that book in your hands
and nothing feels better [ __ ] hey man
give it up for him that's brilliant well
done yeah he's good to see you go he
came to he came to one of my Sony's to
one of his what was he like tell me it
was like an [ __ ] to signing I know it
was awesome put the picture with them
and talked with him a little bit before
the signing actually began so I wasn't
holding up the crowd and yeah it was it
was great just to be able to talk to you
guys because like I said I listened to
you pretty much every Sunday that's when
I'm going out and doing 15 to 25 miles
and it's good it keeps me keeps me
moving and keeps me focused on just
keeping that energy in my head and the
creativity rolling through there 15 to
20 miles yeah on what in a car like on
your your own leg like Forrest Gump on
the legs
lieutenant damn that's impressive Jesus
man that's far I thought maybe a bike or
something just by just running I will
try harder on the podcast for us
didn't realize we were being used as
go-go juice that's not that hard yeah
yeah work smarter not harder give it up
for ad Thank You it so but before we go
yeah did you have like one moment at
this convention that will be the the
memory that you take away from them yeah
laying on the floor with my kid on the
stage at all age watching the trailer
and listening to at work that felt
awesome like you know I I shared like
you know over the course of 25 [ __ ]
years of doing this many moments of like
with producers with casts with people
like oh [ __ ] it worked like you know you
make you feel clever and [ __ ] that
moment I shared with a human being that
came out of my balls so [ __ ] surreal
to look over at like my little [ __ ]
female twin my distaff twin and like
know what she's thinking the same thing
I'm [ __ ] thinking it said but it is
really really kind of special and then
hands and cement was pretty [ __ ] dope
hmm what about you there's there's a guy
who's come to the show a couple of times
I don't want to blow his name up or
anything but he came to the last signing
that I did on Sunday and he was like hey
man like I was already here I already
got the pin I just wanted to give you
something it's like oh alright [ __ ]
that's cool and he reaches into his bag
and he's like listen I've been listening
to the podcast a lot and like you and
Kev but you know you inspired me to kind
of chase my dreams and get on the path
and like start writing and I said I felt
that if anybody should own the first
appearance of black panther it should be
you and he reached into his bag and he
gives me like fantastic for like number
50 whatever that is 52 the first
appearance of black panther holy [ __ ]
and I was just like what did he bring
for me that's really beautiful yeah
and I just I didn't know what to say
like I I I'm not equipped or prepared to
deal with that in any way but it was
just like dude thank you so much like I
I got no words for that and I have no
words for any of it like this this I put
it up on Instagram a couple days ago but
like I am I never wanted this life you
know like I never set out to like have
cameras painted at my face oh this life
there's this life this public life I was
like you've been pursuing writing for
quite some [ __ ] time
you can't be like how is this happening
I never wanted this it's like oh hello
is this the writers room I stumbled in
yeah what are you guys doing in here are
you gonna pay me you mean the public the
guys [ __ ] I never it was never a dream
that I had I never I never aspired to
this but I'm super grateful that it
happened and to be able to tell you know
tell my story to people be able to talk
and be able to to explain my perspective
on the world is fantastic and awesome
and I never take it for granted and so
when that dude just gave me that it's
like I every time somebody's like I'm a
fan I'm a fan like that I just touched
my heart because I am NOT to the depths
of my soul it touches me so much so
thank you to that guy thank you to
everybody who [ __ ] comes and watches
us be the [ __ ] idiots here for like
two and a half hours because I love it
to death yeah me too it's my favorite
thing to do in the world the before we
get out of here just a reminder we do
have a movie coming out Jay and Silent
Bob reboot we're coming to your negative
woods to show you the movie me and Jay
in person go to reboot Roadshow calm to
buy tickets if you're like I ain't
paying [ __ ] $50 to watch a movie go
[ __ ] yourself silly bill but you're
still somehow interested in seeing that
movie fathom events is gonna be having
two screenings October 1517 screwed
theaters everywhere we make it very easy
to sneak preview the movie then we're
going on tour for a long [ __ ] time in
J six months the movie all over the
place right now there's 30 dates up if
you don't see dates near you trust me
they're [ __ ] coming so we'll be doing
this for quite some time so if you don't
see it through fathom and you don't see
it during the reboot Roadshow the idea
the tour is
we like we open in October I think 20th
in Chicago tour happens on the 20th then
like Friday the Friday following the
movie comes out in Chicago because we'll
have gone to Chicago done a bunch of
[ __ ] local press pumped it up and
then platform it out there so there's
like gonna be three ways to see the
[ __ ] movie long before it ever gets
to like Home Video and stuff like that
why did I [ __ ] bring it up Oh in the
process of the trailer going out there
are a lot of our secrets about the movie
got released and stuff one of the
best-kept of which was Ben Affleck is in
the movie as well then returns and plays
Holden in the movie and I've told the
story about how it all happened you
could find it anywhere online I won't
belabor it here as well but I'm on a
[ __ ] streak I'm on a roll right now
because like that happened months ago
we're making the movie and stuff people
have just found out about it but I got
somebody I had to i'll close the show on
this because it's so [ __ ] weird and
wonderful and it shows you if you stick
around long enough like time heals all
[ __ ] wounds and all right I don't
know how else to explain it I got a text
this morning from a number that I've
seen pop up on my phone quite regularly
like every few weeks and I assumed I
don't answer I don't know if you do the
same thing I only answer numbers I know
so if somebody [ __ ] calls me a number
I don't know I don't answer the phone my
numbers been released on the internet so
you know chances are at some 4chan er
you know or something like that
so I've tend to not answer the phone but
you know you'll see numbers come up
again and again and I'm like oh that
must be some auto dialer or blah blah
blah so I've seen this number come up
try to call me and I never [ __ ] answer
this morning it came up three times I
was like Jesus this [ __ ] it they're
really trying to [ __ ] sell me
something and [ __ ] didn't answer then
like five minutes later a text pop up
from that [ __ ] number where in the
numbers in California and the text said
dear Kevin
I have pictures I want to send you I
need your home address love bdub all one
word be edu be and I'm like bdub they
know my name who the [ __ ] is I don't
know any bdub and then I was like wait a
second I know only one BW in this world
and so I wrote texted back Bruce with a
question mark and he wrote back yeah man
how are you [ __ ] Bruce Willis texted
me [ __ ] nowhere man and then I was
like holy crap how are you he's like
great I got pictures of you all and
sending these pictures where can I send
him and so I gave him a P o box that we
send all the mail to and stuff and then
I was sitting there going how do I knows
the same I said you free to talk and he
said yeah call me and I called them and
[ __ ] like goddamnit
it was either Ralph Garman doing an
incredible impression or it was [ __ ]
Bruce and we just chit chatted for like
10 minutes and he goes I found these
pictures I was looking through these
pictures he's gone I see pictures of
Kevin I say to myself Kevin should own
these so here I am I was like hi didn't
mention any of the friction or anything
like that
I wasn't like do you remember cop-out
but like it was [ __ ] lovely I might
have said some [ __ ] about you yeah a
little bit
hope he didn't read that book it was
really [ __ ] lovely just heard from
him out of the [ __ ] blue man so
[ __ ] strange so you never know and
reach out to an old friend or somebody
that you thought would never be a friend
again again you never know what bridges
you can mend it's crazy
yeah Oh that'd be amazing honestly if he
called me was like I want to make
cop-out to I would seriously entertain
the notion like go back and fix the past
that works out in movies all the time
are you low-key we got no more show do
we we got no more [ __ ] [ __ ] ladies and
gentlemen have you had a good time this
evening I cannot thank you enough give
it up for the guy standing next to me
without whom we got no show mr. Marc
[ __ ] Menard and and that is fat man
I'm back our fat man beyond for this
week man I'm Kevin Smith I'm Morgan tune
in next time same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or you-tube
get calm / Kevin Smith feeling good of
all Korea good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you